being visible is a real privilege and
sometimes you know
for a trans person being visible could
cost you your life
so i had a lot of anxiety now that i was
visibly trans
to people you know going into bathrooms
it was a different experience
now as you know people were giving me
you know the double look
so i'm trying to like control my anxiety
but it was always sky high
every time i went out i was glad to be
be a rock tensions were were definitely
high and we were just like hoping for
the best and i was like you got this
you got this we can do it here's the
pulsations of the heart
i always want to be a father but i never
thought
i would be the one that actually carried
the child
oh my goodness hi precious hi miles how
are you guys doing thank you so much for
your time during this
this wild time in the world we're doing
wonderful
we have been in quarantine since march
and we have little zane
and we have had the time of
our lives we've watched a lot of sesame
street it's been great to watch her grow
too and it hit all these little
milestones of course
we have to talk about your big special
which is airing this week on tlc
my pregnant husband when you get
approached
to really kind of expose your life
in a vulnerable way like doing a special
like this
how was how did you react what did you
guys think i actually really wanted to
share my story and to share my journey
um already going through ivf there's
already not a lot of stories out there
and then being a trans masculine person
there's really not
a lot of stories out there so i kind of
did it for my younger self
and also a stat coming out of glad it
says that 80
of all americans don't know anyone
that's trans
so also you know me and precious both
have the privilege to be
you know seen so since we had that
privilege we said let's share our story
i'm also from nebraska and i
understand the deep need for more
inclusive narratives
of family so bringing zayn into the
world was just a restorative opportunity
for me to create a new experience and
association
with the the word motherhood and i also
feel that
we as trans people that we deserve
depictions of
us loving each other we deserve
resilient narratives
you know of narratives that aren't
harmful about us
about us being killed or about us being
uh
novelties uh in in media so
we feel that this is about
representation
of two black trans people loving each
other
uh and starting a family out of that
love i identify as
transmasculine i'm masculine all the way
down
to my core i just happen to have the
equipment
to birth a child was there any
hesitation
was there anything where you were like
i'm willing to share my story
but this is off the table i mean of
course
you know oftentimes when trans stories
are told they often want to talk about
you know
our bodies and what we have done to our
bodies and this story is about
you know my body and what my body is
going through the journey that i'm going
through
so it was a little hesitation of you
know
hoping that the story would be done
tasteful you know that when you look at
you know the powers that be
and who's actually in charge at the end
of putting these
stories together there's not a lot of
people at the table that you know
share any of my identities often so um
that was like my only kind of hesitation
but then i kept thinking you're doing
this for your 12 year old self this
story needs to be told
throughout the entire experience miles
and i
were very communicative
with production there was a lot of give
and take
uh in terms of the way that we wanted
our
our story told and we feel that it
represents
who who we are miles and i have this
very interesting relationship with our
our story
is that we let people in but we don't
let people
in to an extent we're going to beyonce
miles i have to ask you what was it like
being a pregnant man
it was an amazing experience for me um
i'm actually looking forward to
hopefully doing it and going through
that process again um there was moments
when you know
my dysphoria you know would flare up
because i wouldn't like it but you know
you know
that's just what that process does you
know so whether i was trans or if i
wasn't you know
that's just what happens you know and i
would always think
of the bigger picture of you know in
nine months i'll be bringing you know
uh a gem of our love into this world
every day i would see him
just be so resilient and i would offer
to uber him to the office
every day because i wanted him to be
safe but
here is miles he's like no i'm going to
take the bus his cute little bump like
coming out of his cute little shirts
his cute little business it was so cute
and we we would
kind of dialogue at the end of the day i
was i was like did
did someone get up for you did someone
stand uh
no the special does a really thorough
job of documenting
the uh the peaks and the valleys the ups
and the downs of your experience
your cervix the bottom part of your
uterus
has gotten somewhat thin you could lose
the pregnancy
are you okay
[Music]
before my mom uh had me she lost
two children you know and it was because
she had a short cervix
you know so um you know talking with my
mom about what i was going through you
know it kind of like and that's watching
it together kind of like brought back
some of those emotions of you know
i could have like lost this child and it
was our last embryo
so that was that was a hard uh part to
rewatch
then we had the incident that miles that
would police brutality
you know when he was out shopping yeah
this on the day of
the baby shower our baby shower one of
the worst days of my life
i got arrested because they thought my
baby bump
was clothes that i had hit it was truly
like one of the
scariest moments of my entire life black
trans
masculine people you know oftentimes we
have to deal with
you know police brutality and police
harassment because you know
often we don't fit into the mold of what
they
feel a man is supposed to you know look
like
how they're supposed to act somebody
mistook you know
a bump it could have been a beer belly
it could have been anything but a bump
under my shirt as clothes you know so
they called the police on me when i exit
the store
you know uh playing close three they
surrounded me and
i didn't know why at first i thought i
was getting robbed and of course they
were rough and
you know they eventually figured out
what was going on because the female
officer lifted my shirt and they all saw
the bomb
but it's like you know growing up as a
black you know a black child i often
have to talk with my parents
about you know how to act you know when
i am you know
and police presence so like i knew what
to do
and it was just one of those moments
where i just had to swallow my pride
you know be rough house you know rough
handled
and just pray that me and the baby make
it okay and
you know thankfully we did it just
brings up
just such hostile feelings of that
my pregnant trans masculine husband
cannot
exist in the world safely while being
pregnant in the special we didn't really
see how that
debacle was resolved did you get an
apology were you released did you get to
go to the baby shower what happened
um i went to the baby shower good
good good that was another day of being
black in america i am extremely nervous
this was our last egg this could be it
my husband is carrying my child
and if i crumble we are not going to
make it through this
cameras in the delivery room a
very intimate moment a family moment
why did you decide to do that i want it
to be an open book
if 80 of americans don't know somebody
trans
now they do and they've experienced a
very intimate moment with me i really
looked out for him in the delivery room
and like you said our conversations with
production
we made sure that they shot from us from
the very corner
uh we were they were almost like a fly
on the wall like they weren't
even there i was in labor for like 18
hours so like
you know i was focused on the goal at
that moment well another reason why i
wanted to have the cameras in there too
was because of
safety you know i knew that if i had a
camera crew following me
in that moment that i would get
top-notch treatment
and we did precious i do have to ask you
what was it like for you
watching miles's pregnancy journey was
there ever
feelings of frustration or like jealousy
that you couldn't be the one
to carry the child no not at all i
celebrate the fact that i had a
pregnant trans masculine husband it was
our
our child and it was it was a part of
the experience of creating that new
trans reality and that new world
that we want to to live in
and so there was never a single day that
i ever felt any kind of
animosity you know you also touch on
anxiety it's a big theme in your story
and i'm so sorry you had to
experience what you did and that it made
you feel that way
um talk to me about you know getting
strange looks
from people um you know whether it was
doctors and nurses or people walking
down the street
how did you deal with it and precious
how did you deal with it how did you be
that support system
being visible is a real privilege and
sometimes you know
for a trans person being visible could
cost you your life
so i had a lot of anxiety now that i was
visibly trans
to people you know um going into
bathrooms it was a different experience
now as you know people were giving me
you know the double look um like i said
the
the experience i have with the police
and shopping so that would just
increase my anxiety and they are doctors
tell me you know when they're pregnant
use your anxiety like breathe try to cop
you know so i'm trying to like control
my anxiety but it was always sky high
every time i went out
it made me feel good that i could
support my husband i was
in awe of him and what he was doing and
yeah i was glad to
be be a rock tensions were were
definitely high and
we were just like hoping for the best
and i was like you got this
you got this we can do it uh our child
is coming so
i think i was just the cheerleader and
in the delivery i i think i
discovered a skill that i didn't know i
had i feel like um out of all the
pregnant trans guys i actually had the
advantage
because my partner actually like
experienced
some of the things that i've experienced
like being trans
so some of the day you know going
through ivf it's like
not only did i have to stop my hormones
that i was taking to make me
look more masculine but going through
ivf i actually had to like
inject myself with some of the same
things that like
you know so it's like being able to just
like talk to her
about some of that stuff i want to fast
forward to an amazing time
december 2019 baby zayn
is born how is parenthood she is
laughing and playing and loves sesame
street
she is she it's a lot like miles
uh that there is a quiet fierceness but
yet she's like her mom that she's very
vocal
so it's it's it's crazy to see little
parts of yourself
in a child she's amazing she's
completely like changed our lives um
for me it's like i didn't really realize
how strong i was
until i've gone through that experience
and i feel you know for it i'm
such a better person and i'm and i know
that i'm a better father for it too
my self-esteem now it's like you know
your body doesn't make you who you are
you know it's like i'm masculine i'm
centered because i'm masculine all the
way down to my core
no matter what my body looks like or no
matter what my body does it's like
i am still this masculine person
and you know it took me a long time to
get this away and
for often for some trans people you know
to get to this feeling
it's you know a surgery for me it was it
was having the kids
as i watched the special i noticed that
the the other couple that's featured
they decided to not assign a gender to
their child who was born they said we're
gonna let
them make that decision as they get
older was that ever a conversation that
the two of you had
i mean of course it was a conversation
but i i feel that you know i told
precious we're just gonna do the same
thing
you know my parents did for me you know
i was my parents little princess
until i was five and i became their
little prince so
you know uh we call her she her she but
we also use they them pronouns you know
but also we're going to raise zane with
the understanding
that gender is on a continuum
and that she has the right to identify
however
she wants to precious you very candidly
spoke about how you didn't have that
same
uh you know grace with with your family
in your situation growing up
now that you're a mom and your life has
changed in such a beautiful way i'm
curious if
you've reconnected with your family or
if you've made any progress
um on that front i have
made a lot of progress since i've become
a mother myself and i'm having zane i
will say that it has been
a completely restorative experience that
has
peeled back so many layers and healed
a deep wound uh in in my life
there are important conversations that
i'm sure you're going to be having with
zayn as she gets a little older and she
can understand
have you guys talked about when you will
tell her about mom and dad being
transgender and how you're going to
explain that to her diversity is at the
core
of my work and at my passions i believe
in order for us to be something we have
to live at first
and so that starts in our home that
conversation has already
started now of exposing zayn to
other walks of life we're teaching her
about
diversity and so she will understand
that we are another kind
of diversity that families come in many
shapes
sizes and forms and that she is
a part of that and that it should be
celebrated our child will also be able
to build strength off of our stores
because she would be able to see that we
were able to overcome things and she
would overcome whatever obstacles or
aggression she faces
god she's still lucky to have the two of
you as parents honestly
of course we're also in the middle of a
civil rights movement right now
and i want to know if that's something
that you guys have discussed about how
you'll you'll talk to zane about
being black in america and how to combat
racism well of course i mean
we're raising a young black child and
anybody that's raised a young black
child knows that this is a conversation
that even happens before they get into
the world we live in a society
where people don't value you just
because the color of their
of your skin so you know we those
conversations have already started
we need people who are the march in the
chant we need people who
are navigating institutions we need
people in government
shaping public policy but
for me in this moment in time
my act of revolution is curating little
black girl joy
for for his saying that our daughter
is is smiling and that she feels
loved our job is to
ensure that whatever
zayn wants to do in this life that she
can do it
the smiles on your faces are infectious
and i can tell how much the two of you
are enjoying parenthood
is there a chance that you're going to
plan to expand the family maybe even
further
of course of course of course and i'll
tell personal time the next one's on her
no but but we do want to expand our
family whether we have another one or we
adopt
and my last question just something kind
of fun that i noticed miley cyrus
follows both of you
all right because we're part of the
happy hippie foundation so
miles and i so when miles and i first
got engaged uh miley invited us to be a
part of a photo shoot
that she did up launching the offset up
her foundation
celebrating trans and jitter not
conforming folks what do you think of
the way she's using her platform
i think it's incredible i think uh
a lot of people have a lot to say about
her
but she has used her platform
to push equality within the lgbt
community she has you know in in the
national conversation
uh for against gun violence you know in
in support of the environment and
pushing against climate change
she she inspires me and zane loves the
hannah montana theme